Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome to The Rest Is History. Now today for me and I imagine for many of you it's a very, very special day. 17th of March every year I wake with a song in my heart, with the music of the harps resounding in my ears, with the laughter of children because it is of course Tom Holland our favorite day it's St Patrick's Day isn't it it is a day in which we celebrate a great
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告单集、提前解锁系列内容，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。今天对我和大家来说，我想都是一个非常非常特殊的日子。每年的3月7日，我醒来时心中都带着歌声，耳边回荡着竖琴的音乐，伴随着孩子们的笑声，因为这当然是汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland）我们最喜欢的一天——圣帕特里克节（St Patrick's Day），对吧？这是一个我们庆祝伟大的
British saint very good so Tom St Patrick's Day um everybody all over the world sort of knows or thinks they know we all think we know what happened with St Patrick's so to sort of to to give you the kind of caricatured version, the Roman Empire falls, the Dark Ages, an age of obscurantism and violence and stuff. I know you don't agree with that, so don't interrupt. So that descends. And then St. Patrick, in my mind, probably wrongly,
英国圣人的日子，非常好。所以汤姆，圣帕特里克节，嗯，全世界的人都知道或者自以为知道，我们都以为自己知道圣帕特里克身上发生了什么。为了给你讲讲那种脸谱化的版本：罗马帝国灭亡，黑暗时代，一个充满蒙昧主义、暴力等等的时期。我知道你不同意这种说法，所以别打断我。总之，黑暗降临了。然后圣帕特里克——在我的印象中，可能不对，
I've always thought of him as a Welshman or maybe a Cumbrian, goes over to Ireland, he kicks out the snakes converts them all to christianity three leaf clover yeah the shamrocks involved yeah he comes to and fro there's pirates there's all kinds of shenanigans amusing shenanigans he dies tremendous figure for Ireland. Everyone loves him. Later on, they start having parades in America. Yeah, it's all people wearing their terrible comedy beards and green hats. And actually, a lot of Irish people find that immensely patronising and annoying.
我一直觉得他是个威尔士人，或者也许是个坎布里安人——去了爱尔兰，他赶走了蛇，把他们全都皈依了基督教，三叶草，对，三叶草也参与其中，对，他来来往往，有海盗，有各种恶作剧，好玩的恶作剧，他死了，对爱尔兰来说是个了不起的人物。每个人都爱他。后来，他们开始在美国举行游行。对，到处都是戴着滑稽可笑的假胡子和绿帽子的人。事实上，很多爱尔兰人觉得这极其居高临下且令人厌烦。
But that, to me, and I think to most people listening to this, is the image of St. Patrick. Now, am I right in thinking, I believe I am, that this is largely balderdash? Well, there are certain trace elements of fact to that. But it's a complicated story, but it's fascinating for everything that makes it complex. Okay. So Patrick did exist?
但在我看来，我想对大多数听这个节目的人来说，这就是圣帕特里克留下的印象。那么，我是不是可以认为——我相信是的——这基本上都是胡扯呢？嗯，其中确实含有某些历史事实的微量元素。这是一个复杂的历史故事，但也正是因为它的复杂性，才显得如此迷人。好吧。那么，帕特里克确实存在过吗？
Patrick definitely existed, but there may, for instance, have been two Patricks. Oh, that's exciting. So that's just one of the many ambiguities, the ambivalences, the uncertainties, the paradoxes that surround and constitute the historical Patrick. It's all about paradoxes with you, Tom,
帕特里克绝对存在过，但比如说，当时可能存在两个帕特里克。哦，这太让人兴奋了！所以这只是围绕并构成历史上的帕特里克的众多模棱两可、矛盾心理、不确定性和悖论之一。汤姆，跟你在一起，所有事情都变成了悖论，
as always on this podcast. But before we get into all that, there is something else that is absolutely sensational and spectacularly exciting about this episode, Tom. Because do you know what today also marks? Is it, by any chance, our very first specially sponsored episode? It is.
就像在这个播客里一贯的那样。但在我们深入探讨这一切之前，汤姆，关于这一期节目，还有另一件绝对轰动且极其令人兴奋的事情。因为你知道今天还标志着什么吗？难道，这莫非是我们的第一个特别赞助节目？正是如此。
Now, listeners will know, we are absolutely no strangers to promotional activities. We make no apology for it. We love it. We can't get enough of it. And if people want to encourage more such activities they are very welcome to do so now our friends at beer 52 who regular listeners will remember they um are offering a case of a free case a free case tom of eight irish beers for st patrick's day and do you know what they have sent some for us to try
听众们都知道，我们对商业推广活动绝对不陌生。我们对此毫不掩饰。我们喜欢它。我们乐此不疲。如果大家想鼓励更多这样的活动，现在完全可以大方地去做。我们的朋友 Beer 52——经常听节目的老听众一定还记得他们——嗯，他们为圣帕特里克节免费提供一箱爱尔兰啤酒，免费的一箱，汤姆！你知道吗，他们还送了一些给我们品尝，
which is brilliant because we're recording this at 10 o'clock in the morning. So it's like being at the airport. Yes, but it's much better than going to a Wetherspoons. There's absolutely no doubt about that. It absolutely is. So, right. So I think we should celebrate this sponsorship with Dominic by toasting the morning. Yeah. Top of the morning. And trying one.
这真是太棒了，因为我们录制这期节目的时候是早上10点。感觉就像在机场一样。没错，但这比去威瑟斯彭斯酒吧（Wetherspoons）要好得多。毫无疑问，绝对是这样。所以，好。我觉得我们应该和多米尼克一起，为这个赞助干杯，向早晨致敬。对，早上好。然后再尝一尝。
Yeah, very good. So we have one here uh it's from um sligo's white hag are you on that white hag brilliant name so i'm three deep already tom i'm on uh i've moved on the new england ipa i've moved in now i've moved on to the uh oh brother brewing milk stout very tasty you can go to beer52.com slash Ireland to claim your free case. You only have to pay for the postage, which is £5.95. So that's beer52.com forward slash Ireland. So Tom, while you're sipping your beer, we have to get into the topic, the thorny issue of St. Patrick. And we've had lots of questions from our listeners about this. And basically the question
对，非常好。我们这里有一罐，嗯，它是来自斯莱戈的“白魔鬼”（Sligo's White Hag），你喝过这个吗？“白魔鬼”，好名字！所以，汤姆，我已经喝了三罐了，我正在喝，我已经换成新英格兰 IPA（New England IPA）了，我现在换成了，哦，兄弟酿造公司（Oh Brother Brewing）的牛奶世涛（Milk Stout），非常美味。你可以访问 beer52.com/ireland 来领取你的免费啤酒。你只需支付 5.95 英镑的运费。网址是 beer52.com/ireland。所以，汤姆，在你啜饮啤酒的同时，我们得进入正题，也就是关于圣帕特里克的这个棘手问题。我们的听众就此提出了很多问题，基本上这个问题
they all want to know is who is St. Patrick And did he really exist? So off you go. He did exist. And this is precisely what makes the topic so interesting. So, Dominic, we did an episode on King Arthur. And we talked about how it is perhaps legitimate to talk about the 5th and 6th centuries in Britain and even more Ireland as being a dark age in the sense that we know nothing about it really we don't have very many sources for it however what we have with Patrick is someone who wrote not one but two pieces of writing yeah that shed a kind of glimmering faint light on the otherwise complete darkness of this period in terms of the written sources. And so he is a figure of
是他们都想知道的：圣帕特里克究竟是谁？他真的存在过吗？所以，请开始吧。他确实存在过。而这正是这个话题如此有趣的原因。所以，多米尼克，我们曾做过一期关于亚瑟王（King Arthur）的节目。我们讨论过，将英国甚至更甚是爱尔兰的5世纪和6世纪视为一个“黑暗时代”——在这个意义上，我们对它一无所知，也没有多少相关史料——也许是合理的。然而，我们关于帕特里克的资料中，有人写下了不止一篇，而是两篇文字作品，
enormous significance, not just for the history of Britain and Ireland, but actually for the whole study of the collapse of the Roman Empire and the period that Peter Brown, the great historian, called late antiquity. So in a sense, we also did an episode on Muhammad. You could situate Patrick in the same kind of world that gives rise to Muhammad. He is a holy man in an age when people are very prone to showing respect for holy men. And what these holy men do is that they tend to go to regions, to areas that are kind of remote from where they've grown up. So if you think of Muhammad leaving Mecca, going to Medina,
是的，它们在文字记载原本一片漆黑的时期，投下了一缕微弱的曙光。因此，他不仅对不列颠和爱尔兰的历史，而且对整个罗马帝国崩溃时期的研究——即伟大历史学家彼得·布朗（Peter Brown）所称的“晚期古代”（late antiquity）——都具有极其重要的意义。从某种意义上说，我们也做过一期关于穆罕默德的节目。你可以把帕特里克放在与孕育穆罕默德相似的世界背景中。他是一个圣人，生活在一个人们非常倾向于对圣人表现出敬意的时代。而这些圣人所做的事情是，他们往往会前往那些远离他们成长之地的地区。所以如果你想想穆罕默德离开麦加前往麦地那，
you think of monks going from kind of settled regions out into the wilds, into the deserts. The story of Patrick is that he goes from Roman Britain, a Roman settlement, and he goes to the wild barbarism, as it seems to him, of Ireland. And this is part of a kind of a churn that will help to facilitate the transformation of the Roman world into the early medieval world. And I think it's a completely fascinating topic. I mean, having flagged that up, I then have to say that it's also a complex topic. You're going to qualify what you've said. Yeah, because again, as with Muhammad, we talked about this, that the stories that are told of
你会想到僧侣们从安定的地区走到荒野中、沙漠里。帕特里克的经历是，他从一个罗马不列颠的罗马定居点出发，前往他眼中荒蛮落后的爱尔兰。这是历史大动荡的一部分，这种动荡将有助于推动罗马世界向早中世纪世界的转变。我认为这是一个绝对迷人的话题。我的意思是，既然已经强调了这一点，我接着必须说，这也是一个复杂的话题。你这是要为你刚才说的话留有余地了。对，因为同样地，就像我们讨论过的穆罕默德一样，几个世纪后流传关于
Muhammad several centuries later may not necessarily map onto the reality of the historical Muhammad the same is true with Patrick so we do have these very very kind of early texts written by him but then of course we have subsequent traditions subsequent accounts and the question of how reliable they are as evidence for the historical Patrick is an absolutely live issue it's very like the story of James Callaghan, Tom. Yes, mythic figure. Let's get to the nitty gritty. So when do we think St. Patrick is born? When and where? Am I right in thinking he is a late antique Melvin Bragg? Well, so does he come from Cumbria? So let's look at the two pieces of writing. The key one
穆罕默德的故事，可能不一定能反映历史穆罕默德的现实。帕特里克也是如此。所以我们确实有这些由他亲手撰写的非常非常早期的文本，但随之而来的当然是后来的传统、后来的记载，而它们作为历史帕特里克的证据究竟有多大可靠性，是一个非常现实的问题。汤姆，这真的很像詹姆斯·卡拉汉（James Callaghan）的故事。是的，一个神话般的人物。让我们直奔主题。那么，我们认为圣帕特里克是什么时候出生的？何时何地？我以为他是个晚期古代的梅尔文·布拉格（Melvin Bragg），我这样想对吗？
really is his confessio, which isn't exactly confession. It's a kind of an account of his life. Infuriatingly, from the point of view of the historian, a substantial proportion of this is kind of it's a tapestry woven out of fragments of the Bible. So there are kind of like almost 400 biblical allusions in it. And that is the focus for Patrick. And the biographical details are relevant only insofar as they sustain his sense, you know, they help him to explain his sense of mission and his understanding of Christ. However, there are clues. So what he says is that his grandfather, Potitus, was a priest, a presbyter, and that his father,
那么，他来自坎布里亚吗？让我们来看看这两篇文字。其中最关键的实际上是他的《忏悔录》（Confessio），这其实并非严格意义上的忏悔，而是对他生平的一种叙述。令历史学家感到气恼的是，其中相当大的一部分，实际上是一幅用圣经碎片编织而成的壁画。因此里面大约有近400处《圣经》典故。而这正是帕特里克的关注点所在。至于生平细节，只有在它们能够支撑他的使命感——也就是帮助他解释自己的使命感和对基督的理解——时，才具有相关性。不过，其中确实有一些线索。所以他说他的祖父波蒂图斯（Potitus）是一名神父，即长老（presbyter），而他的父亲
Calpurnius, was a deacon. So again, a kind of a priest within the church, but also a decurion, which is a kind of, he sits on the curia, which is the local town or city council. So what he's describing there is the infrastructure of Roman Britain. And Tom, just to quickly jump in, this is at a point when Christianity is the state religion at this point? Yeah, so it's in the aftermath of Constantine's conversion. Christianity has definitely spread to Britain. How far is much debated and the evidence of Patrick's life sheds a shed, you know, sheds a light on that, perhaps. But what we see there certainly is that Patrick, so Patricia, his name, Patricius, you know, Patrician, it's a Roman word redolent of kind of nobility.
卡尔普尼乌斯（Calpurnius）是一名执事。所以同样，他既是教会内的一名神父，也是一名“十人长”（decurion）——这是一种相当于他坐在地方城镇或城市议会（curia）中的议员。因此他所描述的，正是罗马不列颠的基础设施。汤姆，我稍微打断一下，这时的基督教已经是国教了吗？对，所以这是在君士坦丁皈依之后的不久。基督教确实已经传播到了不列颠。传播了多远争议很大，而帕特里克的生平证据或许能为此照亮一线生机。但我们在那里看到的确是，帕特里克——所以帕特里西乌斯（Patricius）这个名字，贵族（Patrician），是一个让人联想到某种贵族的罗马词汇。
So he's upper class. Yeah. His father and his grandfather are figures of moment. They are part of the civic government of Roman Britain, but they are also figures within the church. And so that suggests the way in which church and the kind of the civic structure of cities is starting to meld and mesh. Sort of interwoven, yeah. Yeah. And civic government in cities is basically dependent on the existence of a broader provincial Roman provincial structure. So the implication is that he's born into a province that is still Roman. Okay, because I just wanted to pick up on that,
所以他是上层阶级。对。他的父亲和祖父都是举足轻重的人物。他们是罗马不列颠公民政府的一部分，但他们也是教会内部的人物。这表明了教会与城市的公民结构开始融合和交织的方式。某种程度上是交织在一起的，对。对。而且城市里的公民政府基本上依赖于一个更广泛的罗马行省地方结构的存续。因此暗示着他出生在一个仍然是罗马行省的地方。好的，因为我只是想顺着这一点追问下去，
because when we did our When Did the Roman Empire Fall podcasts a few weeks ago, there was a sense that Britain was slightly semi-detached as you entered the 5th century. But you're sort of saying that the life of St Patrick implies that Roman structures are still actually very deeply embedded and if this is Cumbria you know it's a long way from Rome I mean it's a long way from the well maybe it's not Cumbria yeah so we're come to so yeah it does it implies that there are um offices that people take on local city councils or town councils. Patrick's father seems to have, he has land, he has slaves. So this is very much still a slave owning property society.
因为几周前我们做“罗马帝国是何时灭亡的”播客时，有一种看法认为，进入5世纪时，不列颠有点处于半脱离状态。但你的意思是圣帕特里克的生平暗示罗马结构实际上仍然根深蒂固？如果这是坎布里亚的话，你知道，这离罗马很远，我是说，离那个……也许这不是坎布里亚？对，所以我们来谈谈……所以是的，这暗示着有一些人们会担任的职务，比如地方市议会或城镇议会的官员。帕特里克的父亲似乎拥有土地，还拥有奴隶。所以这在很大程度上仍然是一个拥有奴隶的财产社会。
This does not seem to be a land that is collapsing into anarchy and barbarism. So there are implications that Roman civic life is continuing to function. So presumably this is either the late fourth century or the first decade of the fifth century. Now, the question of where it is, and there's been a number of questions on that, haven't there? So Father Darren J. Zanel, I've heard claims he's from several different places. Where is he really from? OK, so again, what Patrick tells us is that he's from a place called Bannovem Taberniae. Taberniae is kind of shops, taverns, it's places that sell things. Bannovem, we can't be certain where that is.
这似乎不是一个陷入无政府状态和野蛮状态的土地。因此这意味着罗马公民生活仍在继续运转。所以据推测，这要么是公元四世纪末，要么是五世纪的第一个十年。现在，关于它究竟在何处，有很多相关的问题，对吧？比如达伦·J·扎内尔神父（Father Darren J. Zanel）问：“我听说他来自几个不同的地方。他到底来自哪里？”好吧，同样地，帕特里克告诉我们，他来自一个叫班诺文·塔伯尼（Bannovem Taberniae）的地方。“Taberniae”有点像商店、小酒馆，是出售东西的地方。至于“Bannovem”，我们无法确定它在哪里。
There have been various theories. One of them is that it's a fort that was known to the Romans as Banner, a horn in Celticic on hadrian's wall now known as bird oswald uh another theory is that it's carlisle which was a kind of a civic center um just south of hadrian well pretty much on hadrian's wall actually yeah however there's a problem there which you put your finger on which is that this is indeed a very very remote kind of frontier region and so far as we know, there are no villas. There's no evidence for any villas that far north. So that would imply that Patrick wasn't, in fact, I think, from Cumbria.
有各种各样的理论。其中一种理论认为，它是罗马人所知的巴纳（Banner）堡垒，在凯尔特语中意为哈德良长城上的“号角”，现在被称为伯德奥斯瓦尔德（Birdoswald）；另一个理论认为它是卡莱尔（Carlisle），那是一个公民中心，位于哈德良长城以南一点，实际上几乎就在哈德良长城上。然而，这里有一个你一针见血指出的问题，那就是这确实是一个非常非常偏远的边境地区，据我们所知，那么靠北的地方并没有别墅（villas）。没有证据表明那么靠北的地方有任何别墅。所以这意味着，我认为帕特里克实际上并非来自坎布里亚。
There's another theory, which is a much later one, which is that he came from Glastonbury. That seems a bit too good to be true, Tom. It does. Also that he's buried there. So that wouldn't go down well with Irish listeners. Exactly like King Arthur. And this is a tradition that's first mentioned by William of Malmesbury,
还有另一种理论，是一个晚得多的说法，即他来自格拉斯顿伯里（Glastonbury）。这听起来似乎有点好得令人难以置信，汤姆。确实如此。而且他还被埋葬在那里。所以爱尔兰听众大概不会买账。这太像亚瑟王了。这是威廉·马姆斯伯里（William of Malmesbury）首先提到的一种传统，
or at least by people who've rewritten William of Malmesbury in the 12th century, but it seems to date back to the 10th century at least. Again, unlikely. I would have thought that the likeliest place is is probably kellyan that would be the one that i would go for which is the fort of the legions in wales it's the great legionary center there would definitely have been taberniae kind of scattered around it uh even after the legions had gone um it's within striking distance of the coast and that's
或者至少是由12世纪重写威廉·马姆斯伯里著作的人提到的，但它似乎至少可以追溯到10世纪。同样，不太可能。我一直认为最可能的地方大概是凯利昂（Caerleon），那是我会选择的地方，也就是威尔士的罗马军团要塞，那里的伟大军团中心。即使在军团离开之后，周围也肯定散落着各种“Taberniae”。它离海岸不远，
important because as we'll go patrick goes on to say he gets captured by pirates and taken away to ireland so it's clearly that was the light the west the west coast is clearly the obvious place isn't it it must be on the west coast i mean there is also there is um an eighth century tradition that he was born in strathclyde so that that's beyond Hadrian's Wall. Again, like King Arthur. Yeah, again. So he's kind of shifting. But unlike King Arthur, we actually, you know, we don't have first-hand evidence from Arthur himself.
这很重要，因为正如我们接下来要说的，帕特里克接着说他被海盗俘虏并带到了爱尔兰，所以很明显，那是……西海岸显然是一个显而易见的地方，对吧？它一定在西海岸。我的意思是，还有一个8世纪的传统认为他出生在斯特拉斯克莱德（Strathclyde），所以那是在哈德良长城以外。又是一个像亚瑟王的故事。对，又来了。所以他一直在变动。但与亚瑟王不同的是，我们实际上并没有来自亚瑟本人的第一手证据。
So we can't even say that Arthur existed. But Patrick, we can. Although, Tom, the St. Patrick of legend and the St. Patrick of history are two very different beasts. And some historians, and maybe I'm jumping ahead, think that there are multiple different people whose lives have found their way into this sort of, the canonical story of St. Patrick, don't they?
所以我们甚至无法证明亚瑟真的存在过。但帕特里克，我们可以。不过，汤姆，传说中的圣帕特里克和历史上的圣帕特里克是两个截然不同的形象。有些历史学家——也许我有点操之过急了——认为有多个不同的人，他们的生平都被汇集并融入到了圣帕特里克的正统故事中，不是吗？
So, yeah, so we'll come to that. But if we stick for now to what Patrick himself tells us, and then we can ask, first of all, how credible Patrick's own account is, and then how it may have been distorted in subsequent decades. Ironically, I have to say the one place we know he didn't come from was Ireland. Yeah, absolutely. Yes.
所以，是的，我们等会儿会谈到这一点。但如果我们现在坚持帕特里克自己告诉我们的内容，然后我们可以先问：帕特里克自己的叙述有多大可信度？以及在随后的几十年里，它又是如何被歪曲的？讽刺的是，我必须说，我们唯一知道他没有来的地方就是爱尔兰。对，绝对是的。
So he's absolutely, he is British and he's Roman. Yeah. And he self-identifies as both. Okay. He's a Roman citizen. He confesses that as a young man he wasn't um a particularly good christian uh age 15 he seems to have done something very naughty for which he gets put on trial do we know um no suspicion taught on we he doesn't say what it was uh mine boggles yeah yeah behind the
所以他绝对是不列颠人，也是罗马人。对。而且他自己也这样表明身份。好吧。他是一名罗马公民。他坦白说，作为一个年轻人，他并不是一个特别好的基督徒。15岁时，他似乎做了一些非常调皮的事，为此他被送上法庭。我们知道……吗？没有，汤姆对此表示怀疑。他没有说具体是什么事。这真让人浮想联翩。嗯，嗯。躲在公交候车亭后面干的吧？然后不久之后，他被海盗抓走并沦为奴隶，他是这么说的。他被带走并卖掉了。他成了一名牧羊人。
bus shelter then shortly after this he gets taken by pirates as a slave, he says. And he gets taken, he gets sold. He becomes a herdsman. So looking after cattle, probably, in the forest of Focklet, he says, which I gather maybe is probably County Mayo. Learns Irish. christian faith deepens there um and then one day six years after his um abduction he hears a voice and this voice says to him you have fasted well soon you must return to your native land and then uh shortly afterwards again this voice says the ship is ready to take you.
所以可能是在福克利特森林（Forest of Focklet）里放牛，据我了解，那可能就是梅奥郡（County Mayo）。他在那里学会了爱尔兰语。并在那里加深了对基督教信仰的理解。然后有一天，在他被绑架六年之后，他听到一个声音，这个声音对他说：“你斋戒得很好，不久你必须返回你的祖国。”然后不久之后，这个声音又说：“船已经准备好接你了。”
However, there's a catch because the voice also says that it's not nearby, but 200 miles away. The voice gives and the voice takes away. Because to be a slave, you know, a runaway slave in Ireland is very dangerous. Because Ireland is a place where you essentially, you have to belong essentially to the equivalent of a kind of a gang. You know, there are all these little monarchies, which again are subordinate to larger monarchies and so on. But basically, if you don't belong,
然而，这里有个陷阱，因为这个声音还说，船并不在附近，而是在200英里外。声音给予，声音也剥夺。因为在爱尔兰做一个逃奴是非常危险的。因为爱尔兰是一个你基本上必须依附于某种“帮派”等同物的地方。你知道，那里有所有这些小君国，它们又从属于更大的君国，诸如此类。但基本上，如果你不属于某个地方，
if you don't have an overlord who can give you protection, you're in real danger. But especially if you're a runaway slave. So the idea that Patrick has made it 200 miles to where this ship is supposedly waiting for him, the implication is that there is the quality of the miraculous to this. So it's probably not to be taken as just a documentary fact. I was about to ask about all this though, Tom. I mean, the captured by the pirates could have happened.
如果你没有一个能为你提供庇护的领主，你就会处于真正的危险之中，尤其是作为一个逃奴。因此，帕特里克跋涉了200英里到达据说正等着他的那艘船，这种说法暗示了其中带有某种奇迹的性质。所以这可能不应该仅仅被当作一个纯粹的纪实事实来看待。不过，汤姆，我正想问所有这些呢。我是说，被海盗俘虏这件事可能是真的。
The voice, I think as secular secular historians we would probably say he didn't get a voice telling him that the ship was 200 miles away also the capture by pirates is very biblical it's very julius caesar it's so entrenched in kind of fables and stuff it is it is so we'll come again we'll come to that when we okay we ask how accurate yeah the account is um so patrick he arrives he finds the ship um they refuse to take him on and he specifies something very interesting which has provoked a lot of um speculation but he says he refuses to suck the breasts of the the people on the ship okay that's a that's an unexpected development yes it is on the ship that's the question so so this so what does this mean so there are scholars who have argued that um if you're in
那个声音，我想作为世俗历史学家，我们大概会说他并没有听到一个声音告诉他船在200英里外，而且被海盗俘虏这一点也极具《圣经》色彩，非常像尤利乌斯·凯撒（Julius Caesar）的经历，它深深扎根于各种寓言之类的东西之中。确实如此，确实如此。所以当我们讨论……时，我们会再次回到这一点。我们来探讨他的叙述究竟有多准确。所以，帕特里克抵达后找到了那艘船，
ireland and you don't have an overlord to look after you yeah you can become you can gain the protection of of a lord by sucking his nipple uh i don't know what to say about that so you know you're you're traveling through ireland uh you're on holiday but everywhere you go you have to suck the nipple of the local the local bigwig that's it that's the implication and the the um the archaeological evidence for this is that um in 2003 two men were found in in in different bogs in ireland uh they were clearly aristocratic they the hands were you know they they weren't rough they weren't peasants they were clearly aristocrats both men had had their nipples surgically removed why would you have it so because you were sick of people sucking it probably to stop them being kings is the implication so you can't offer people the
但他们拒绝带他走，并且他具体提到了一个非常有趣的事情，这引发了大量的猜测。他说他拒绝吮吸船上那些人的乳房。好吧，这是一个意料之外的发展。是的，在船上，问题就在这里。所以这到底意味着什么呢？有些学者认为，如果你身处爱尔兰，却没有一个领主来关照你，你可以通过吮吸一个领主的乳头来获得他的保护。我不知道该对此作何感想。所以，你知道的，你在爱尔兰旅行，你在度假，但无论走到哪里，你都必须吮吸当地大人物的乳头。就是这样，这就是那层含义。而对此的考古证据是，
nipple that is so weird well it is weird and so the other theory yeah is that um it's an allusion to a biblical verse okay verse in isaiah you shall suck the milk of the other theory yeah is that um it's an allusion to a biblical verse okay verse in isaiah you shall suck the milk of the gentiles so perhaps that's what that's sort of more banal but probably but a bit more persuasive i would say than this business about doing a road trip and having to suck nipple yeah but i mean it's something for the irish tourist authorities perhaps to why don't they make more play of that? I mean, madness. I know. The whole advertising campaign.
在2003年，爱尔兰不同的泥炭沼里发现了两具男尸，他们显然是贵族，他们的双手并不粗糙，不是农民，显然是贵族。这两个男人的乳头都被手术切除了。为什么要切除呢？因为你厌倦了别人来吮吸它。可能的含义是，这样人们就不能再让你吮吸乳头了，所以你不能再把乳头提供给别人。这太诡异了！嗯，这确实很诡异。所以另一种理论是，这是对《圣经》经文的一种暗示。《以赛亚书》中的一节经文：“你必吮吸外邦人的奶……”另外一种理论是，这是对《圣经》经文的一种暗示。《以赛亚书》中的一节经文：“你必吮吸外邦人的奶……”所以也许这就是……这听起来有点平庸，但比起公路旅行还得吮吸乳头这种事，我个人觉得可能稍微更有说服力一点。但这或许可以成为爱尔兰旅游局可以利用的一个点，他们为什么不在这方面多做做宣传呢？真是太疯狂了。我知道，整个广告宣传活动都可以这样搞。
Anyway, so basically the people on the ship decide that actually they are going to let him come with them. They sail for three days. They land. They then journey for 28 days through a wilderness. The food runs out. They turn around and say say i thought that you were meant to be a chosen one of god what's going on and miraculously a herd of pigs arrive so they kill the pigs and have a massive barbecue that almost so that's good yeah um they then journey
无论如何，基本上船上的人决定让他们同行。他们航行了三天，登岸了。然后他们穿过一片荒野跋涉了28天。食物耗尽了。他们转过头对他说：“我以为你是上帝的选民呢，这到底是怎么回事？”然后奇迹般地，一群猪出现了，于是他们杀猪并搞了一场盛大的烧烤。几乎……所以这倒挺好。他们接着又跋涉了10天，
for another 10 days and presumably he then arrives at his parents house or whatever doesn't actually specify where he's turned up right but the best the best thing is that he says that this is 60 days but obviously three days on the ship yeah 28 days going through the wilderness further 10 days that doesn't count to 60 days and so do you know what um roy fletchner who's written uh the most recent study of Patrick's life. I'm not as familiar with Roy Fletchner's work as I should be. Well, he's got a brilliant theory as to why Patrick says 60 when it doesn't add up to 60. Right. Patrick was simply not very good at maths.
想必他随后就回到了父母的家中之类的地方，但他并没有明确指出他究竟出现在哪里。不过最棒的是，他说这段旅程一共是60天。但显然，在船上3天，穿过荒野28天，再加上另外10天，这加起来根本不到60天。所以你知道吗？撰写了关于帕特里克生平最新研究的罗伊·弗莱赫纳（Roy Fletchner）……我对罗伊·弗莱赫纳的作品不像我应该的那样熟悉。好吧，他有一个绝妙的理论，用来解释为什么帕特里克在总数凑不够60天的情况下偏说那是60天。对。帕特里克只是数学不太好。
Oh, wow. So it's a brilliant passage. He goes through all the kind of biblical reasons perhaps you know is he you know 40 days but he says basically there aren't any you know this isn't something you can get from the bible and he says maybe he just wasn't very good at maths that's a very literal approach to patrick's story i would say not that i'm dissing roy fletchner no no he's he i mean he's very very alert to the kind of the biblical context for it but i think it's a it's an interesting and i thought engaging well because this is very much patrick's own right maybe he just wasn't very good at adding things up you know i think someone would have proofread
哦，哇！所以这是一个精彩的论述。他排查了所有《圣经》中可能的原因，比如是不是40天之类的，但他基本上说，没有任何依据，这不是你能从《圣经》里找出来的数字。他说，也许他只是数学不太好。我觉得这对待帕特里克的叙述是非常字面的解读方式，当然我可不是在贬低罗伊·弗莱赫纳。不，不，他——我是说，他对其中的《圣经》语境非常非常敏锐。但我认为这是一个有趣的、引人入胜的观点。因为这确实是帕特里克自己的文字，也许他只是不擅长做加法。你知道，我想总该有人帮他校对一下的吧，比如像文字编辑什么的？不管怎样……
it though like a copy editor or something right anyway um so he's come back so he comes back yeah and then the next thing we know he's about 45 and he's become a bishop. That's a leap. And he's hanging out in Britain again. And while he's with his parents back in Britain, he sees a vision of a man called Victoricus. And this man, Victoricus, nobody has a faintest idea who he is. Seems to be coming from Ireland with lots of letters and all these letters when he reads them are written by people from Ireland saying please come over and we beg you come and walk among us again right but hold on how would people remember him I mean it's just a vision it's a vision it's
所以他回来了。然后我们知道的下一件事是，他大约45岁时成了一名主教。这可真是个飞跃。而且他又回到了不列颠闲晃。当他回到不列颠与父母团聚时，他看到一个幻象，梦见了一个名叫维克多利库斯（Victoricus）的人。而这个名叫维克多利库斯的人，谁也不知道他是谁。他似乎从爱尔兰带着许多信件走来，而当帕特里克阅读所有这些信件时，上面写着爱尔兰人民的话：“请过来吧，我们恳求你，再来我们中间走走吧。”等等。等等，人们怎么会记得他呢？我的意思是，这只是一种幻象。这只是一个幻象。幻象，好的，好吧，这是一个幻象。
a vision okay fine fine it's a vision yep and when you read it you get this sense of incredible kind of intensity this is you know, he's seeing this. He's struggling to put it into words what exactly it is he saw. But it's this kind of incredible sense that God wants him to go and preach beyond the Irish Sea in this land that had never been a part of the Roman Empire. Yeah. Is, you know, the epitome of barbarism for for generations of roman geography britain is still roman britain is still going at this point he's 45 no britain by this point must must have must have as i was about to say we must be post kind of 410 or whatever by now yeah um
当你阅读它时，你会感受到一种难以置信的强烈情感。这就是，你知道的，他看到了这一切。他正努力用语言表达他究竟看到了什么。但这是一种不可思议的感觉，仿佛上帝希望他去爱尔兰海对岸、这片从未成为罗马帝国一部分的土地上宣讲。在几代罗马地理学家的眼中，不列颠仍然……罗马不列颠在此时还在持续。他当时45岁。不列颠到这个时候一定已经……像我刚才要说的那样，我们一定已经进入公元410年或之后的时期了吧？
but enough of roman society survives that he hasn't been troubled by anarchy or something and he's happy to make this journey off to ireland to carry the that he hasn't been troubled by anarchy or something and he's happy to make this journey off to ireland to to carry the gospel he doesn't say he doesn't tell us anything about his life in britain okay uh presumably staying with his uh well okay so one thing we can know is that when he crosses to ireland he clearly takes quite a lot of movable goods with him right which enables him to kind of cut a dash you know so he's he's a figure of some moment yeah and he he tells us that um he gets thousands of converts that he gets the sons of of uh various irish kings converting their daughters uh becoming nuns
但是，罗马社会的残余足够维持，以至于他没有受到无政府状态的困扰，而且他也很高兴踏上前往爱尔兰传播福音的旅程。他没有说，他没有告诉我们他在不列颠的生活情况。好吧。我们可以知道的一件事是，当他横渡到爱尔兰时，他显然随身携带了相当多的动产，这使他能够表现得非常阔绰，所以他是一个有头有脸的人物。并且他告诉我们，他获得了数以千计的归信者，
uh the irish kings don't seem to have liked the daughters becoming nuns they don't seem to particularly ejected to the the sons becoming christian and it may be that they're kind of you know hedging their their bets that they're staying pagan their sons are becoming christian their daughters are maybe more important tools for kind of marriage alliances or something they don't want to you know them becoming nuns is a bit of a pain in that or or nuns allowed to get married at this point it's probably no no they're not okay he is he's uh gives us his portrait of an island that has been won by his missionary efforts um for christ that it's a church full of missionary zeal now this dovetails with the other piece of writing that has survived which is um a letter that he's written to a man called Caroticus, who seems to be a Romano-British slave trader.
他让爱尔兰各个国王的儿子们皈依，让他们的女儿们成为修女。爱尔兰的国王们似乎不太乐意看到女儿们成为修女，但他们似乎并不特别反对儿子们皈依基督教。这或许是因为他们正在留有退路：他们的儿子皈依基督教，而女儿们或许是某种婚姻联盟的更重要工具。他们不希望女儿们成为修女，因为这会带来麻烦。或者说当时的修女被允许结婚吗？大概不，没有，她们不能。好吧，他给我们描绘了一幅爱尔兰的画卷，这片土地通过他的传教努力为基督赢得了信仰，这是一个充满传教热忱的教会。这与另一份幸存的文字资料完美契合，
And he has crossed the Irish Sea from Britain and has abducted a load of Irish converts, probably on Easter Day, and taken them off as slaves. And Patrick is writing, basically excommunicating him, telling Caroticus that he's an absolute rotter and to hand over the slaves. It seems from the letter that this isn't very successful and that Caroticus and his followers just kind of laugh at the very idea that they should right but patrick is patrick in this letter you get a sense of this you know the power of the holy man yeah his power to curse those who oppose him can i ask you a question can i jump in now tom um you said the power of the holy man so peter brown or you
也就是他写给一个名叫卡罗蒂库斯（Caroticus）的人的一封信。此人似乎是一个罗马-不列颠的奴隶贩子。他从不列颠横渡爱尔兰海，绑架了一批爱尔兰的基督教归信者——很可能是在复活节那天——并将他们抓走当作奴隶贩卖。帕特里克写这封信基本上是为了将他逐出教会，告诉卡罗蒂库斯他是个彻头彻尾的混蛋，并命令他交出奴隶。从信中来看，这似乎并没有取得太大成功，卡罗蒂库斯和他的追随者只是对他们应该……的说法嗤之以鼻。但帕特里克在这封信中展现了圣人的力量，
mentioned at the beginning of the podcast one of the great living history one of the greatest living historians one of his early works was about the holy man in late antiquity and he was talking particularly about holy men in the eastern roman empire and syria and so on does patrick do you think play the same part as being the holy man who comes in and is a kind of arbiter and is a he he stands apart from the traditional power structures and therefore is able to kind of exert a different kind of authority and so on do you think yeah i'm sure that's part of it and i'm sure that um for reasons that we can't be certain about he clearly has a kind of charisma that derives from his claims to a supernatural power yeah and it may be that he brings a kind of a sense of the
他有能力诅咒那些反对他的人。我能问个问题吗？汤姆，我能现在打断你一下吗？你刚才提到了圣人的力量——彼得·布朗，也就是你在播客开头提到的那位当今最伟大的历史学家之一，他早期的著作之一就是关于晚期古代的圣人的，他当时特别谈到了东罗马帝国和叙利亚等地的圣人。你认为帕特里克是否扮演了同样的角色？作为一个介入其中并充当某种仲裁者的圣人，他超然于传统的权力结构之外，因此能够施加一种不同类型的权威等等，你觉得是这样吗？
power of of rome but not in such a way as to seem kind of overtly threatening of the independence of the various irish kings but a sense that there is a kind of a greater dimension beyond ireland that perhaps that the irish can become a part of So I was going to ask about that, because in the previous podcast, we did a very timely podcast about the Vikings in the East and the origin stories of Russia and Ukraine. And one of those stories was about Vladimir the Great and his conversion to Byzantine orthodoxy. And obviously, one reason Vladimir does that is because it's political. He wants to ally himself with the great superpower of the Eastern Mediterranean. But the Irish conversion, I mean, if the Roman Empire is dwindling and if Roman power is breaking up in Britannia,
是的，我确信这是其中一部分。而且我确信，由于我们无法完全确定的原因，他显然拥有一种独特的个人魅力，这种魅力源于他声称自己拥有超自然力量。也许他带来了一种罗马力量的感觉，但又不会以一种对各个爱尔兰国王的独立性构成公开威胁的方式出现，而是让人感觉到爱尔兰之外还有一个更宏大的维度，爱尔兰人或许可以成为其中的一部分。我正想问这个，因为在上一期播客中，我们做了一期非常应景的节目，讲的是东方的维京人以及俄罗斯和乌克兰的起源故事。其中一个故事讲的是弗拉基米尔大帝（Vladimir the Great）皈依拜占庭东正教。显然，弗拉基米尔这样做的原因之一是出于政治考量，他想与东地中海的超级大国结盟。但爱尔兰人的皈依——我的意思是，如果罗马帝国正在衰落，如果罗马在不列颠尼亚的权力正在瓦解，
in a sense, what's in it for them in following Patrick? I mean, what does Patrick have to offer? And also, Tom, am I not right in thinking, I mean, I'm just basically easily swayed by the questions from our listeners. Tony Larkin has a question. He says, why doesn't Patrick get the credit for introducing Christianity to Ireland when it seems there were previous missions? So is Patrick the first? And why does he in particular have this?
从某种意义上说，追随帕特里克对他们有什么好处呢？我是说，帕特里克能提供什么？而且，汤姆，我这样说对不对？我是说，我基本上很容易被听众的问题所左右。托尼·拉金（Tony Larkin）有一个问题，他说：“为什么帕特里克没有因为将基督教引入爱尔兰而受到赞誉，而此前似乎已经有过其他传教活动了呢？”所以帕特里克是第一个吗？为什么唯独他拥有这样的声誉？
Because what's the sort of political subtext to his kind of conversion story? Okay, it is true that this is to plunge into the kind of the heart of some of the puzzles that surround what Patrick tells us. So what is Patrick doing in his Confessio, in this account of his life? I mean, it is a biography. It is a kind of self-exculpation. He is clearly, he's being attacked by people. He's trying to defend himself against kind of various charges that are never quite stated. So that's absolutely part of it as well. But it is, as I said at the beginning, it is absolutely a statement of mission. It's a sense that he's been called by Christ to take the gospel to lands beyond the Roman world. Now, the questioner is absolutely right that he is not alone in going to Ireland, it seems, because there is another figure who has not at all kind of entered the mainstream of Irish folklore or Catholic piety, a guy called Palladius.
因为他的皈依故事背后有什么政治潜台词吗？好吧，这确实触及了围绕帕特里克言论的一些谜团的核心。那么，帕特里克在他的《忏悔录》（即这份生平自述）中究竟在做什么？我的意思是，这是一部传记，是一种自我洗脱。他显然受到了某些人的攻击，他试图为自己辩护，反驳那些从未被明言的各种指控。所以这绝对也是其中的一部分。但正如我一开始所说，它绝对是一份使命宣言。这是一种感觉，即他被基督召唤，将福音带到罗马世界之外的土地上。现在，提问者完全说对了，他似乎并不是唯一一个前往爱尔兰的人，因为还有另一个人，他根本没有进入爱尔兰民间传说或天主教虔诚的主流，这个人叫帕拉狄乌斯（Palladius）。
Whereas we have no contemporary references to Patrick outside his writings, with Palladius we don't have his writings, but we do have references to him in authenticated chronicles of the time. So he's mentioned by a guy called Prosper of Aquitaine, who's writing kind of annals of the years as they go by. And Prosper, he's in Aquitaine, so he's distant from Ireland. But he writes in 431 that in that year, Palladius, who had been consecrated by Pope Celestine, is sent as the first bishop to the Irish believers in Christ. So what's the relationship of Palladius and Patrick? Are they the same person? Well, so this was the argument that a scholar called Thomas Francis O'Rahilly in 1942 put forward. And his theory was that there was the Patrick that we know, the guy who's written the Confessio,
尽管我们在帕特里克的著作之外没有关于他的当代文献记载，但我们虽然没有帕拉狄乌斯的著作，却在当时经过验证的编年史中找到了关于他的记载。所以他被一个叫阿基坦的普罗斯珀（Prosper of Aquitaine）的人提及，此人正在逐年撰写编年史。普罗斯珀身处阿基坦，所以他离爱尔兰很远。但他在431年写道，在那一年，由教皇教宗才立（Pope Celestine）祝圣的帕拉狄乌斯，被派遣作为第一任主教去见爱尔兰信奉基督的人。那么，帕拉狄乌斯和帕特里克是什么关系？他们是同一个人吗？好吧，这就是432年一位名叫托马斯·弗朗西斯·奥雷利（Thomas Francis O'Rahilly）的学者提出的观点。他的理论是，有我们所知的帕特里克，也就是写了《忏悔录》的那个人，
but that Palladius was also he was a patrician so he was palladius patricius and that he was the first guy to go there yeah so that's the thesis and it's it's a thesis that remains kind of very very current but i think there is a telling difference between um palladius and patrick which is that prosper says of palladius that he's sent to the Irish believers in Christ who are already in Ireland. So presumably those are slaves, British slaves, perhaps, or Gaelic slaves who've been taken to Ireland. And Celestine himself, the Pope who's sending Palladius, had specified that bishops should only go to places where they wanted.
但帕拉狄乌斯也是……他是一位帕特里cian（贵族），所以他就是帕拉狄乌斯·帕特里修斯（Palladius Patricius），而且他是第一个去那里的人。这就是这个论点，而且这个论点至今仍然非常流行。但我认为帕拉狄乌斯和帕特里克之间有一个显着的区别，那就是普罗斯珀说帕拉狄乌斯被派去寻找那些已经在爱尔兰的爱尔兰基督徒信徒。所以据推测，那些人是奴隶，也许是不列颠奴隶，或者是被带到爱尔兰的盖尔人奴隶。派遣帕拉狄乌斯的教皇才立本人曾明确规定，主教只能去那些他们想要主教去的地方。
And so what you have there is an echo of the assumption that was absolutely hardwired into the Romans and preceded the conversion of the empire to Christianity, that the fruits of Roman civilization should not wantonly be bestowed on barbarians. And the kind of the Christian manifestation of that is the assumption that christianity is for people within the limits of the empire right so this is something that is being so augustine the saint who we talked about in the the episode on the fall of the empire that the great bishop of um hippo in north africa who is um essentially arguing why it doesn't really matter that rome, because ultimately what matters is that the church survives. He is kind of groping his way towards an idea that the Christian mission
因此，你在这里听到了一种深深烙印在罗马人心中并先于帝国皈依基督教的假设的回声，即罗马文明的果实不应轻率地赐予野蛮人。而这种思想的基督教表现形式就是一种假设，即基督教只适用于帝国境内的居民。所以，正如我们在帝国灭亡那一期节目中讨论过的圣奥古斯丁（Augustine）——北非希波（Hippo）的伟大主教——他基本上在争论为什么罗马的灭亡并不重要，因为最重要的事情是教会能够存续。他当时正在摸索一种观念，即基督教的使命
is for everybody. It's for people beyond the limits of the empire, as well as for those within. But even he doesn't kind of quite arrive at the conclusion that you get with Patrick, because the key thing about Patrick is, and this is the Patrick of the Confessio, the guy who we've been talking about, his assumption is that the gospel should be taken beyond the seas to people who know nothing about it at all. And that's what makes him such a revolutionary figure, right? I mean, that's what makes him an extraordinary, groundbreaking figure in the late roman world is that right it does and i will quote again from from um peter brown the great historian of the holy man in late antiquity and he says of patrick's originality was that no one within
是面向所有人的。它既面向帝国边界之外的人，也面向帝国境内的人。但即使是他，也没有完全得出你在帕特里克身上看到的那种结论，因为帕特里克最关键的地方在于——也就是我们一直谈论的那个《忏悔录》中的帕特里克——他的假设是，福音应该被带到海外，带给那些对它一无所知的人。这正是让他成为一个革命性人物的原因，对吧？我的意思是，正是这一点让他成为晚期罗马世界中一个非凡的、具有开创性的人物，难道不是吗？确实如此。我再次引用彼得·布朗的话——那位晚期古代圣人研究的伟大历史学家——他对帕特里克的独创性评价是：“在西方基督教世界里，从来没有人有过像这样的想法，从来没有人曾被这样的信念所支配。”
western christendom had thought such thoughts as these before had ever previously been possessed by such convictions um he's the first person basically to get the sense that barbarians living beyond the frontiers of the empire, that they should be brought to Christ. And this is, I think, a kind of momentous development because it means that the Irish church, as it comes to flourish and grow, is committed to the idea that um missions should be sent yeah and this is you know how the irish saved civilization that's the you know how thomas carhill in his book frames it yes the impulse for irish saints to go to go into exile you know whether that is to uh skelling michael this kind of remote island off-island,
他基本上是第一个意识到生活在帝国边疆之外的野蛮人应该被引向基督的人。我认为这是一个意义重大的发展，因为它意味着爱尔兰教会后来的繁荣和成长，致力于这样一个理念：应该派遣传教士去远方。是的，这就是“爱尔兰如何拯救了文明”（how the Irish saved civilization）的由来，正如托马斯·卡希尔（Thomas Cahill）在他的书中所阐述的那样，爱尔兰圣人们前往流放之地的冲动，无论是去斯凯利格迈克尔（Skellig Michael）这种海岛上的偏远修道院，
which you'll know is in Star Wars. Yeah. Or it's like St. Brendan to take ship and go out into the Atlantic and discover perhaps new worlds there. I was about to say, didn't Irish missionaries go to Iceland? To go to Iceland, perhaps. Yeah. And of course, famously, St. Columbanus goes to Gaul and establishes a kind of great missionary tradition there.
你知道的，这在《星球大战》里也有。或者像圣布兰登（St. Brendan）乘船出海进入大西洋，或许在那里发现了新的世界。我正要说呢，难道没有爱尔兰传教士去过冰岛吗？或许去过冰岛吧。是的。当然，还有著名的圣高隆庞（St. Columbanus）前往高卢，并在那里建立了一种伟大的传教传统。
And St. Columba, he goes to Iona and establishes, he starts the kind of the process of bringing Christ to the Picts an important part of the Anglo-Saxon church and then in turn inspires Anglo-Saxon missionaries to go to Saxony and to Germany and to Scandinavia. So it is, I think, a kind of, Patrick is for that reason, a really significant figure. Okay, Tom, I think we should take a break because while you've been talking, listeners may be wondering why i've been quite quiet that's because you've been talking about st patrick and i've been basically devoting my attention to my free beers from beer 52 uh so i've just finished my um oh brother brewing company milk stout which i have to say tom was delicious very rich velvety a lovely drink and uh have you been getting on while you've been chatting well i haven't i haven't had a chance because i've just been jabbering away oh that is but if you've really missed out what folly but if we're if we're going to um for a break now i can um have a quick
还有圣高隆（St. Columba），他前往爱奥那岛（Iona），并建立、开启了将基督信仰带给皮克特人的进程，这是盎格鲁-撒克逊教会的重要组成部分，进而激励了盎格鲁-撒克逊传教士前往萨克森、德国和斯堪的纳维亚。所以，我认为帕特里克因此真的是一个非常重要的人物。好了，汤姆，我觉得我们应该休息一下，因为在你说话的时候，听众可能在纳闷为什么我一直挺安静的，那是因为你一直在谈论圣帕特里克，而我基本上把注意力都放在了 Beer 52 赞助的免费啤酒上。呃，所以我刚刚喝完了我的“哦兄弟酿酒公司”（Oh Brother Brewing Company）牛奶世涛（milk stout），我必须说，汤姆，这酒太美味了，非常浓郁、如丝绒般顺滑，真是一款迷人的饮品。呃，你一边聊天一边喝得怎么样了？嗯，我没有，我没有机会，因为我一直在喋喋不休地讲个不停。哦，那是——不过如果你真的错过了，真是太愚蠢了。不过如果我们，如果我们现在要休息一下，我可以——快速地
sip well listen in the commercial break and then uh and then before you do that tom i think it would be remiss of me not to say to people that if you want to taste them for yourself you should go to beer52.com slash ireland to claim your free case and we will be back after the break with more on St Patrick and some more on the beer goodbye I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
抿上一口。好吧，在商业广告时间听听看，然后——然后在那之前，汤姆，我觉得如果不告诉大家，如果你想亲自品尝它们，你应该去 beer52.com/ireland 领取你的免费箱装啤酒，这将是我的失职。我们将在休息后回来，带来更多关于圣帕特里克以及更多关于啤酒的内容。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐剩下什么》（The Rest is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History, and as if you didn't know uh sponsored this week by beer 52 now beer 52 i know you all want to hear a lot more about beer 52 and probably less from tom about st patrick uh beer 52 is actually the biggest beer club in the world and every month they send their members a case of beer from a different part of the world and wouldn't you know it for this month being st patrick's day it Day it is Ireland Tom have you chosen your beer
如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集和抢先购买现场门票的权益，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史剩下什么》（The Rest Is History），本周节目正如你可能知道的那样，由 Beer 52 赞助。现在讲到 Beer 52，我知道你们所有人都想听到更多关于 Beer 52 的信息，而可能不想听汤姆讲太多关于圣帕特里克的废话。Beer 52 实际上是世界上最大的啤酒俱乐部，每个月他们都会向会员寄送一箱来自世界不同地区的啤酒。你猜怎么着，这个月正好赶上圣帕特里克节，
for part two of the podcast I have I have I have Dominic what is it it's um it's an Irish lager from O'Hara's Brewing Company a fine drink Tom I heartily heartily recommend I had that while you were talking about pirates and Christianity and stuff. It has watered my tonsils. Splendid. Splendid. So that I'm now able to continue with St. Patrick. So that's beer52.com forward slash Ireland. And that's the word beer, the numbers 52.com forward slash Ireland.
节日的主题就是爱尔兰。汤姆，你为播客第二部分选好啤酒了吗？我选了，我选了，多米尼克，是什么？这是一种来自奥哈拉酿酒公司（O'Hara's Brewing Company）的爱尔兰拉格（lager），真是一款好酒，汤姆，我衷心、衷心地推荐。在你谈论海盗、基督教之类的事情时，我喝的就是这个。它滋润了我的喉咙。太棒了。太棒了。所以我现在能够继续讲圣帕特里克了。网址是 beer52.com 斜杠 Ireland（爱尔兰）。也就是“beer”这个词，加上数字 52 点 com 斜杠 Ireland。
So now on to the other business of the podcast, which is St. Patrick. So let's talk about the kidnap, because you hinted in the first half that the kidnap by the pirates, that there may be more to that than meets the eye. And indeed, Tom, shockingly, it may not have happened. So what's going on? This is the thesis of Roy Fletchner, whose book St. Patrick Retold is really fantastic and fizzing with all kinds of brilliant insights and theses.
那么现在进入播客的另一项业务，那就是圣帕特里克。所以让我们来谈谈绑架事件，因为你在前半部分暗示过，海盗的绑架事件可能并没有表面上那么简单。而且确实，汤姆，令人震惊的是，这可能根本没有发生过。所以这到底是怎么回事？这就是罗伊·弗雷特奇纳（Roy Flechner）的论点，他的书《重述圣帕特里克》（St. Patrick Retold）非常精彩，里面充满了各种绝妙的见解和论点。
Fizzing like a New England IPA or an Irish lager from O'Hara's brewing company. Exactly so, Dominic. Brilliantly done. Exactly so, yes. Please keep these promotional inquiries coming to other companies. And he asks, wasrick really kidnapped right so the context for this is that there is a lot of kidnapping and slaving going on yeah i mean no one questions that yeah uh we we have in roman historians uh you know there are
像新英格兰 IPA（New England IPA）或奥哈拉酿酒公司（O'Hara's Brewing Company）的爱尔兰拉格一样充满活力。完全如此，多米尼克。干得漂亮。完全如此，是的。请继续向其他公司提出这些促销咨询。他问，帕特里克真的被绑架了吗？对，这背后的背景是当时有很多绑架和奴役事件发生。是的，我的意思是，没有人对此提出质疑。是的，呃，我们有罗马历史学家——你知道，有
accounts of kind of meltdown in roman britain Britain and Irish raiders are part of the kind of consortium of Picts and Saxons and all these other guys who are kind of breaking into Roman Britain. So we absolutely know that that is going on. We also know that there are so many slaves in Ireland that the word for a slave girl becomes a kind of, you know, it comes to denote a unit of value in exchange. So what is it? But Komal. Okay. I hope that it's probably pronounced completely different. Because we'll, yes.
关于罗马不列颠崩溃的记载，爱尔兰袭击者是皮克特人、撒克逊人和所有这些闯入罗马不列颠的其他家伙组成的联盟的一部分。所以我们绝对知道这种事正在发生。我们还知道，爱尔兰有那么多的奴隶，以至于奴隶女孩的代名词变成了一种，你知道的，它成了一个交易价值单位。所以这是什么？但是 Komal。好吧。我希望它的发音可能完全不同。因为我们会，是的。
To be fair, you're on your sixth beer of the podcast. I mean, you can be excused. I'll be absolutely fluent in it by the end. To that extent, it's, you know, it's entirely plausible that Patrick might have been taken. However, you know, we looked at the implausibility of the fact that he might, you know, did he really manage to walk 200 miles to a ship? But again, you could say maybe, or maybe, as you said, it's a kind of, you know, it's a biblical illusion or whatever.
公平地说，你已经在播客里喝了第六杯啤酒了。我的意思是，你可以被原谅。到最后我一定会说得非常流利。从这个角度来看，帕特里克被抓走是完全有可能的。然而，你知道的，我们审视了这样一个事实的不合情理之处，即他可能——他真的设法步行 200 英里走到一艘船上吗？但话又说回来，你可以说也许吧，或者正如你所说的那样，这是一种圣经隐喻之类的东西。
The theory that Fletchner puts forward in his book, he goes back to look at the role that Patrick's father is playing in the Curia, in the kind of the town council of lot of weight put on the shoulder of those with land and property and slaves and possessions that kind of obliged you essentially to contribute your time and your money to caring for the city. And that in the kind of the dying days of the Roman Empire in the West, quite a lot of the elites got fed up with this and tried to kind of wriggle out of their responsibilities. And his thesis is that actually, what Patrick perhaps has done, and perhaps what he's justifying in the Confessio. So he keeps kind of emphasising again and again, I was kidnapped, kind of implying that people have been saying, well, maybe you weren't. Fletcher's argument is that perhaps he was a tax exile. So just before he becomes 16, when he comes of age,
弗雷特奇纳在书中所提出的理论是，他回过头去审视了帕特里克的父亲在库里亚（Curia），也就是罗马地方议会中所扮演的角色。这给那些拥有土地、财产、奴隶和资产的人肩上施加了沉重的负担，本质上，这迫使你贡献自己的时间和金钱来照顾这座城市。在西罗马帝国的残存日子里，相当多的精英对这一点感到厌烦，并试图摆脱他们的责任。他的论点是，实际上，帕特里克可能做过的事，以及他在《忏悔录》（Confessio）中可能在为之辩解的事——所以他一次又一次地强调，我被绑架了，这似乎在暗示人们一直在说，嗯，也许你根本没被绑架。弗雷特奇纳的论点是，也许他是一个税务难民。所以在他在 16 岁成年之前，
perhaps he took his inheritance and went to Ireland and hung out there for six years. And then the Roman Empire collapsed and then came back. I thought I was being cynical in this podcast, but I mean, that's a very, very cynical view of St. Patrick's behaviour, isn't it? Yeah, it is quite. Do you, I mean, what do you think?
也许他拿了遗产去了爱尔兰，在那里闲逛了六年。然后罗马帝国崩溃了，接着他又回来了。我以为我在这个播客里已经够愤世嫉俗了，但我的意思是，对于圣帕特里克的行为来说，这是一个非常、非常愤世嫉俗的看法，不是吗？是的，确实挺愤世嫉俗的。你，我的意思是，你怎么看？
Do you think, do you buy the argument? I think the problem with that is that it absolutely requires Patrick to have been born at a time when the frameworks of Roman rule are secure enough that you get in trouble. Yeah. You know, the whip hand of central Roman government is pretty strong. Yes. Which then requires you to push Patrick's birth,
你觉得，你买账这个论点吗？我认为其中的问题在于，它绝对要求帕特里克出生在一个罗马统治框架足够稳固的时代，以至于你会陷入麻烦。是的。你知道，中央罗马政府铁腕统治相当强有力。是的。这就要求把帕特里克的出生时间推前，
perhaps to, you know, I don't know, 380 or something like that. Further back into the fourth century. Yeah. And there's, and there's kind of further,
也许推到，你知道的，公元 380 年左右或者类似的时间。更早地回到公元四世纪。是的。而且还有，而且还有一种——
you know, there are kind of other pieces of evidence within the Confessio that suggests that actually Patrick died kind of certainly second half of the fifth century. So it's tricky. It requires Patrick to have been very cynical and self-interested early in his life and then to have this miraculous transformation into a much more altruistic figure later on, doesn't it? I mean, that's not impossible,
你知道，在《忏悔录》中还有其他一些证据表明，实际上帕特里克去世的时间肯定在公元五世纪的下半叶。所以这很棘手。这要求帕特里克在生命的早期非常愤世嫉俗、唯利是图，然后后来又经历了一场奇迹般的转变，变成了一个更加利他的人物，不是吗？我的意思是，这并非不可能，
I suppose. That's not impossible. And that, of course, is the archetype of that is Saul, who persecutes the church and then becomes, you know, as St. Paul becomes the kind of the great missionary. Or Augustine, I suppose. Yeah, or Augustine. But Paul, perhaps, is the obvious example because he's the great missionary. So he's going out in converting those who know nothing about christ yeah so i don't know i mean we the truth is we will never know okay well that's a very never say in a history podcast but i don't think it is i don't think it is because i think the fact that it's the fact of what we do know that's exciting you know as i said at the beginning because otherwise we know nothing about this period we have no written sources written by someone from britain at all okay this period so that's what makes it so exciting let's
我想。这并非不可能。当然，这其中的原型就是扫罗（Saul），他迫害教会，然后成为，你知道的，正如圣保罗（St. Paul）那样成为伟大的传教士。或者奥古斯丁（Augustus），我想。是的，或者奥古斯丁。但保罗也许是最明显的例子，因为他是伟大的传教士。所以他走出去，去皈依那些对基督一无所知的人。是的，所以我不知道，我的意思是，真相是我们永远不会知道。好吧，这是历史播客里绝不能说的话，但我不认为如此。我不认为如此，因为我认为我们所知道的事实才是令人兴奋的，正如我一开始所说的那样，否则我们对这段时期一无所知。我们没有任何由来自不列颠的人所写的手写史料。好了，这段时期就是这样，所以这才是它如此令人兴奋的原因。让我们
push on a bit tom because uh i'm keen to get back eventually to the beers um patrick dies when do we reckon you say that basically the second half of the fifth century or is that too late well we're given two dates in subsequent chronicles uh one is 457 one is 493 okay i mean so that's quite a big you know you pay your money it takes your choice okay and of course it's perfectly possible that neither of them are correct but what that does suggest is that the tradition is that he died in the second half of the fifth century does that imply there could be two different people though again that died in those two years or do you possibly so that's so that that is that is the thesis that maybe the first Patrick died in uh in 457 and the second one in 493 yeah so that has been argued and then obviously
继续推进一点，汤姆，因为——我很想最终回到啤酒的话题上——帕特里克是什么时候去世的？我们估计是什么时候？你说基本上是公元五世纪下半叶，还是说这太晚了？嗯，后来的编年史给出了两个日期：一个是 457 年，一个是 493 年。好吧，我的意思是，这是一个相当大的差距，你可以花钱买单，也可以自己做选择。好吧。当然，这两者都不正确也是完全有可能的。但这也表明，传统上认为他死于公元五世纪下半叶。但这是否意味着可能存在两个不同的人呢？他们死在这两个不同的年份，或者你觉得有可能吗？所以这就是那个论点，也许第一个帕特里克死于公元 457 年，第二个死于公元 493 年。是的，所以曾有人这样争论过，然后显然
after that point he he has this tremendous afterlife so he does to go back to Tony Larkin's question he does get the credit for introducing Christianity he is seen as the kind of father of Irish Christian identity. Well, how does that? Yeah. Come on then. How does that happen?
在那之后，他获得了巨大的后世声誉——所以回到托尼·拉金（Tony Larkin）的问题，他确实因引入基督教而受到赞誉，他被视为爱尔兰基督教身份的父亲。好吧，这是怎么做到的？是的。那么，快说吧。这是怎么发生的？
Okay. He's one of two people who can test for that. Actually, the person who really gets in the middle ages is Bridget, who your fans of the World Cup of Gods will remember. Well, they won't because she did. She crashed out so early,
好吧。他是争夺这一称号的两个人之一。实际上，在中世纪真正赢得这一头衔的人是圣布丽吉特（Bridget），“诸神世界杯”（World Cup of Gods）的粉丝们会记得她。好吧，他们不会记得，因为她被淘汰得太早了，
Tom. Yeah, she did. So St. Bridget of Kildare is, is Patrick's great rival as the kind of the alpha saint, the uber saint for Ireland. So Kildare is in South Ireland. Patrick is associated with Armagh in the north of Ireland, in Ulster. Again and again, when you look at the posthumous reputations of saints and indeed of holy men, so you could say the same about Muhammad.
汤姆。是的，她确实被淘汰了。所以基尔代尔的圣布丽吉特（St. Bridget of Kildare）是帕特里克的强大竞争对手，被视为爱尔兰的超级圣人、终极圣人。基尔代尔位于爱尔兰南部。帕特里克则与爱尔兰北部阿尔斯特（Ulster）的阿马（Armagh）联系在一起。一次又一次，当你审视圣人乃至神圣之人的死后声誉时，关于穆罕默德，你也可以这么说。
It really matters the places that they're associated with because the posthumous holiness that they shed gives power and authority and prestige to these places. And they become centers of pilgrimage. The authority of the person who may have founded the church or you know the mosque or whatever becomes incredibly important yeah um and essentially what the what the um what the monks of armagh are doing is bigging up patrick in almost every way they can so there is a slight problem that he's not buried there um he's he's buried it down patrick yeah um county down and so they have to come up with a reason for why he's there and so they say that he was in armagh um he died there but then angels took his body to uh to down patrick and of course the people in glastonbury would say that he's he died in glastonbury so
与他们相关的地点真的非常重要，因为他们散发出的死后神圣性赋予了这些地方力量、权力和声望。它们成为了朝圣中心。创立教会或清真寺等机构的人的权威变得极其重要。是的。嗯，本质上，阿马的僧侣们所做的就是在几乎所有他们能想到的方面把帕特里克吹捧起来。所以这里有一个小问题，那就是他并没有被埋葬在那里——他被埋葬在唐帕特里克（Downpatrick），
you know there is this kind of you know it's like greeks fighting over the bodies at of the dead at before troy people it really matters where these saints end up anyway so it's a problem that he's not buried armagh but not an insuperable one um the monks of armagh produce uh certainly two biographies of him um from the late uh the late seventh century so kind of 690s that have survived now the question is of course how reliable are these and it's in these biographies that you get the accounts that most people will have heard of patrick confronting druids right yeah someone's talking about this yeah so he uh the high king of the irish at tara has a whole load of druids around him
唐郡（County Down），所以他们必须编造一个他为什么在那里的理由，因此他们说他曾在阿马，他死在那里，但后来天使把他的尸体带到了唐帕特里克。当然，格拉斯顿伯里（Glastonbury）的人会说他死在格拉斯顿伯里，所以
no one is allowed to uh to light a fire easter patrick lights a fire and the druids look out and they say unless this fire is extinguished then verily i say unto the fire shall be lit that will never be extinguished at all kind of words to that effect wow that's very uh cranmer archbishop cranmer isn't it um well the Martyrs Memorial. Well, yeah, I suppose. But actually, of course, what it is, it's Patrick confronting a posse of pagan sorcerers. It's Moses confronting the priests of Egypt in front of Pharaoh. It's Elijah confronting the priests of Baal.
你知道，这就好比希腊人在特洛伊城前争夺死者的尸体。圣人最终安息在哪里真的非常重要。无论如何，他没有埋葬在阿马是个问题，但并非无法克服。阿马的僧侣们制作了——至少有两部关于他的传记，从晚期——公元七世纪末期，也就是大约 690 年代流传至今。现在的问题当然是，这些传记有多大可靠性？正是在这些传记中，你才听到了大多数人都听说过的关于帕特里克与德鲁伊（druids）对抗的故事，对吧？是的，有人在谈论这个，是的。所以他——爱尔兰至高王（High King）塔拉（Tara）周围有一大群德鲁伊。
These are kind of archetypal stories with very, very obvious biblical precursors. I mean, that's the problem, Tom, with all these sources, though, isn't it? I mean, this is the problem with all sources written in this period, or indeed earlier, that they all have ultimately kind of devolved into archetypes. And when you dig into the stories, it's very hard to tell what's specific truth and what is purely a kind of a formula. It absolutely is and so um caroticus for instance the the romano british slave trader um one of these saints lives written
没有人被允许——点燃复活节之火。帕特里克点燃了一把火，德鲁伊们向外张望并说道：“除非这火被扑灭，否则我诚心向你宣告，将会有永不熄灭的圣火被点燃。”大致是这样的话。哇，这非常像克兰麦（Cranmer），坎特伯雷大主教克兰麦，不是吗？嗯，还有殉道者纪念碑（Martyrs' Memorial）。好吧，是的，我想是的。但实际上，当然，这是帕特里克与一群异教巫师的对抗。这就像摩西在法老面前与埃及祭司对抗，就像以利亚（Elijah）与巴力（Baal）的祭司对抗。
in the in the 690s says that um he was a british king that he uh ruled uh in strathclyde so presumably on the great rock of dumbarton the kingdom of Alclut um but if you're tempted to believe that as a as an authentic uh you know an authentic report you then face the problem that this life also says that when Caroticus died he turned into a fox so how you kind of integrate that into yeah yes so so it's a it's a it's a problem um there is one perhaps one intriguing fragment of evidence that does preserve an authentic detail um and this was uh it appeared i read it on a a blog post that's devoted to um to rude words golly you're really, you're doing the absolute forensic research here, Tom. And it's written by Vox
这些都是具有非常、非常明显的圣经前身的原型故事。我的意思是，这就是问题所在，汤姆，所有这些资料都有这个问题，不是吗？我的意思是，这也是这个时期或更早时期撰写的所有资料的问题，它们最终都退化成了原型。当你深入研究这些故事时，很难分辨什么是具体的事实，什么纯粹是一种套路。确实如此，所以——例如卡罗蒂库斯（Caroticus），那个罗马-不列颠奴隶贩子——其中一本在 690 年代撰写的圣徒传记说，他是一位不列颠国王，他在斯特拉斯克莱德（Strathclyde）统治——所以大概是在邓巴顿巨岩（Great Rock of Dumbarton）的阿尔克鲁特王国（Kingdom of Alclut）。但如果你倾向于相信这是一个真实的——你知道的，真实的报告，那么你就会面临这样一个问题：这本传记还说，当卡罗蒂库斯死时，他变成了一只狐狸。所以你该如何将这一点融入——是的，所以——所以这是一个问题。
Hiberionicum, who has an excellent Twitter account, which I commend. And he gives this account of Patrick is sleeping on the Sunday, on the Sabbath, day of rest, and the pagans are busy working. I think they're digging a moat or
不过，或许有一个耐人寻味的证据碎片确实保留了一个真实的细节——这就是——我是在一个专门讨论粗鲁言语的博客上看到它的。天哪，汤姆，你真的是在做绝对的法医研究啊。这篇文章由 Vox
something. Patrick tells them to stop. The pagans are busy working. I think they're digging a moat or something. Patrick tells them to stop. The pagans tell him to piss off. And then, and I quote, Holy Patrick said, Mudabroth, in spite of all your labor, you shall achieve nothing. And so it happened. The following night, there came a heavy storm and stirred up the sea, and the storm destroyed all that the pagans had done,
Hiberionicum 撰写，他有一个很棒的 Twitter 账号，我向大家推荐。他讲述了这样一件事：帕特里克在周日（也就是安息日、休息日）睡觉，而异教士们正忙着干活。我想他们是在挖护城河什么的。
as the man of God had said. Now, what I read there in english is written in the original in latin yeah but mudabroth yeah that's not a latin word that i gather from is a britonic word so that's a the language that patrick would have spoken as a britain yeah apparently mudabroth is a kind of jumble of various you know three britonic words and i you know I speak with no expertise whatsoever. I'm merely reporting what is written in this fascinating article that it means, may God's judgment be on you, or may God's doom be on you.
帕特里克叫他们停下。异教士们叫他滚开。然后，我引用原话：“圣帕特里克说：‘Mudabroth，不管你们怎么卖力，你们什么也得不到。’结果果真如此。第二天晚上，刮起了一场大风，搅动了海水，暴风雨摧毁了异教士们所做的一切，正如神人所说的那样。”现在，我在英文里读到的这些，在原文中是用拉丁语写的，对吧？但是“Mudabroth”——那不是拉丁语单词，我从中所了解到的是，这是一个布立吞语（Britonic）单词，所以那是帕特里克作为不列颠人会说的一种语言。显然，“Mudabroth”是各种——你知道的，三个布立吞语单词的拼凑。而我（你知道的）没有任何专业知识，我只是在转述这篇迷人文章中所写的内容，它的意思是：“愿神的审判降临在你身上”，或者“愿神的末日降临在你身上”。
So perhaps that is an authentic patrician swear word, or exposition. Well, Tom, we're whizzing through. I mean, time is kind of catching up up with this so i would like to get on to to two more aspects in particular before we turn to the question of purgatory one of those is snakes now it's well known that saint patrick cast the snakes out of ireland but i think i'm right in saying there never were any snakes in ireland is that
所以这也许是一个真实的帕特里克式的脏话，或者诅咒。好了，汤姆，我们正在飞速前进。我的意思是，时间对我们来说有点紧迫了，所以在我们转向炼狱的问题之前，我想特别探讨另外两个方面。其中之一就是蛇。众所周知，圣帕特里克把蛇从爱尔兰驱逐了出去，但我认为我说得没错吧：爱尔兰从来就没有过蛇。这是
correct yeah well there's an excellent question from Huel George. Should Patrick be considered an ecological villain for reducing the serpentine biodiversity of Ireland? But he didn't. He shouldn't. There never were any snakes. There never were any snakes. I'm not a natural historian,
正确的吗？是的，好吧，这是休·乔治（Huel George）提出的一個极好的问题：“鉴于爱尔兰蛇类生物多样性的减少，帕特里克是否应该被视为一个生态罪人？”但他并没有。他不应该被视为罪人。爱尔兰从来就没有过蛇。爱尔兰从来就没有过蛇。我不是自然历史学家，
so I don't know why there were never any snakes, but there just weren't, were there? Well, they never crossed the Irish Sea. No. So who knows why not? They couldn't swim. They couldn't swim. Right. Okay. So that's the end of the snakes what about the shamrocks well no oh you want to say something about snakes well
所以我不知道为什么爱尔兰从来没有过蛇，但就是没有，对吧？嗯，它们从来没有穿过爱尔兰海。不。所以谁知道为什么没有呢？它们不会游泳。它们不会游泳。对，好吧。蛇的故事就到这里。那么三叶草呢？不，哦，你还想对蛇说点什么吗？
no it's just that um the way that this legend grows up is interesting because it was noted by you know roman geographers noted that there was no snakes in in ireland i mean they understood that um and the legend that um a christian holy man had banished them, it's not original to Patrick. So it gets associated with St. Columba, I think, first of all. Bede reports that reptiles, you know, full sweep can't survive in Ireland, that it just kills them the moment they land there. And then the story seems to have originated around 12 13 centuries so much i mean but basically almost a thousand years later well even then you get skepticism so gerald of wales who is very skeptical about almost everything that the rsa um he's very very contemptuous of the
不，只是——这个传说滋生的方式很有趣，因为正如罗马地理学家所注意到的那样，爱尔兰没有蛇——我是说，他们了解这一点——而“一个基督教圣人驱逐了它们”的传说并不是帕特里克的原创。所以它最早似乎是与圣高隆（St. Columba）联系在一起的。比德（Bede）报告说，爬行动物——你知道的，全面来看——无法在爱尔兰生存，一登陆那里就会死掉。然后这个故事似乎起源于大约 12、13 世纪。我的意思是——基本上几乎是一千年后。好吧，即便如此，你也会遇到怀疑论者——比如对几乎所有关于爱尔兰的事都高度怀疑的威尔士的吉拉德（Gerald of Wales）。他非常、非常轻蔑
whole idea it is more probable that from the earliest times and long before the foundation of the faith this island was naturally without them. OK, so now let's take the other great thing that people know about St. Patrick, which is that he waved shamrocks around to demonstrate the truth of the Trinity. Is this also untrue, Tom? The earliest attestation is 1680s. Yes, I saw that. So very late. So more than a thousand years after the event. So almost certainly not true. So how did the shamrock come to be associated with St. Patrick? Or is it purely just a sort of creation of early modern stroke modern nationalism, would you say? the backdrop is heightened Catholic Protestant tension, particularly in Ireland. So presumably that is the context for it. It's Protestants and Catholics competing over Patrick.
整个想法：“更有可能的是，从最早的时期起，早在信仰建立很久之前，这个岛屿自然就没有这些东西。”好，现在让我们来看看人们了解圣帕特里克的另一大标志，那就是他挥舞着三叶草来证明三位一体的真理。这也是假的吗，汤姆？最早的文字记载是在 1680 年代。是的，我看到了。所以非常晚。也就是在事件发生一千多年之后。所以几乎可以肯定不是真的。那么三叶草是如何与圣帕特里克联系在一起的呢？或者它纯粹只是早期现代/现代民族主义的一种创造，你会这么说吗？背景是日益加剧的天主教与新教的紧张关系，尤其是在爱尔兰。所以这大概就是它的背景。这是新教徒和天主教徒在争夺帕特里克。
And then this question about purgatory. I mean, I'm actually just reading that off your notes, so I don't know what it refers to at all. I'm not going to pretend any knowledge. Well, so in the Middle Ages, the story arises um this island in county donagall is an entranceway to purgatory and the story goes that patrick was shown it by christ himself and this is well i mean relative to the shamrock this is quite early so this is um 12th century late 12th century yeah and pilgrims would go there and they're kind of very, very detailed accounts
然后是关于炼狱的问题。我的意思是，我其实只是从你的笔记上读到这个，所以我完全不知道它指的是什么。我不会假装自己懂。好吧，在中世纪，这个故事出现了——多尼戈尔郡（County Donegal）的这个岛屿是通往炼狱的入口，故事说帕特里克是基督本人带去参观的。这是一个——我的意思是，相对于三叶草而言，这相当早，所以这是——12世纪，12世纪末，是的。朝圣者会去那里，而且有关于人们在其中看到什么的非常、非常详细的记载。关于这一点，有一个精彩的记述。我是通过斯蒂芬·格林布拉特（Stephen Greenblatt，伟大的莎士比亚学者）了解到这个故事的。他写了一本名叫《哈姆雷特在炼狱》（Hamlet in Purgatory）的书。是的。他对此进行了精彩的书写。不可避免地，恐怕它在 1632 年被新教徒查封了。
of what people saw in it. And there's a brilliant account of this. This is how I came across the story. In Stephen Greenblatt, the great Shakespeare scholar, he wrote a book called Hamlet in Purgatory. Yeah. And he writes wonderfully about this. And inevitably, I'm afraid it got shut down by Protestants in 1632.
托马斯·克伦威尔（Thomas Cromwell）对这个故事可不会高兴。不，奥利弗（Oliver）也不会。所以我想方济各会（Franciscans）现在管理着它，但我想你不能再进入洞穴寻找炼狱了。但这是帕特里克的传奇故事交织进爱尔兰的植物、动物群和自然环境中的另一种方式。如果我们现在快进
Thomas Cromwell would not be pleased with this story. No, nor Oliver. So I think the Franciscans run it today, but I think you can't go into the cave and look for purgatory. But that's another way in which the legends of Patrick has kind of woven itself into the flora and the fauna and the natural environment in Ireland. And then if we sort of fast forward
——因为我们离结尾很近了——如果我们快进到现代，圣帕特里克和圣帕特里克节显然已经变得——就像通常情况那样——其主要推动力之一是爱尔兰裔美国人。所以你会在
now, because we are quite close to the end, if we fast forward to the present day, St. Patrick and St. Patrick's Day has obviously become, as is so often the way, one of the great drivers for it is kind of Irish-Americans. And so you have
美国城市的爱尔兰人社区中看到圣帕特里克节游行。特别是从 19 世纪末开始，然后在整个 20 世纪不断增强影响力，显然现在已经完全制度化了。现在有这样一种事情，爱尔兰总理（Taoiseach）会去白宫，向总统赠送一盆三叶草以及诸如此类的东西。此外，英国王室成员也会向爱尔兰近卫军（Irish Guards）赠送一盆三叶草以及诸如此类的东西。但你认为，汤姆，这是否仍然具有某种宗教维度？特别是，你是否认为它也具有某种维度——我的意思是，这很奇怪，不是吗？圣帕特里克已经成为爱尔兰的象征，在某种程度上，我想也是爱尔兰天主教、天主教爱尔兰的象征，尽管他并不是爱尔兰人。我的意思是，这是一种很奇怪的事情，不是吗？嗯，我认为这正是他的故事如此……我的意思是，这是一个人们绝对可以
St. Patrick's Day parades among kind of Irish communities. And so you have St. Patrick's Day parades among kind of Irish communities in American cities from especially governing strength in the sort of late 19th century and then throughout the 20th century and obviously now completely institutionalized. And there is this sort of thing now that the Taoiseach will go to the White House
进行调整的故事。所以显然，帕特里克节在美国变得如此重要的原因之一是，漂洋过海来到新世界的爱尔兰人是——你知道的，他们是移民。是的。就像帕特里克一样。他们算是在重演他的航程。完全正确。事实上，在 2017 年，当恩达·肯尼（Enda Kenny）去白宫过帕特里克节而特朗普在白宫时，肯尼非常尖锐地指出，圣帕特里克是移民的主保圣人。是的，这有点在戳特朗普的肋骨。
and present the president with a bowl of shamrocks and all this kind of stuff. But also that a member of the British royal family will present the Irish guards with a bowl of shamrocks and all this kind of stuff, but also that a member of the British royal family will present the Irish guards with a bowl of shamrocks and all this kind of thing. But do you think, Tom, that this still has a kind of religious dimension? And in particular, do you think it also has a dimension of, I mean, it's odd, isn't it, that St. Patrick has become this symbol of Ireland, and to some extent, I guess, of Irish Catholicism, of Catholic Ireland, when he wasn't Irish. I mean, that's a kind of strange thing, isn't it? Well, I think that that's what makes his story so... I mean, it's one that people can absolutely
所以我觉得这挺有帮助的。我认为，是的。所以帕特里克同时被天主教徒和新教徒争夺。比如阿马，你知道的，帕特里克的伟大崇拜中心，它被爱尔兰教会（Church of Ireland）接管了。是的，我认为在——你知道的，在 19 世纪末 20 世纪初，他显然与爱尔兰民族主义联系在一起，因此也与那种天主教的根基联系在一起，所以这也是其中的一个重要部分。因此它在 1903 年成为了爱尔兰的国定假日。是的，在一位爱尔兰民族主义议员的推动下，是的，我记得是在威斯敏斯特，但是他们也规定那天酒吧必须关门。好吧，一直
adapt. So obviously, one of the reasons why Patrick's Day becomes so important in America is that Irish people who have traveled across the Atlantic to the New World are, you know, they're immigrants. Yeah. Just as Patrick was. They've kind of reenacted his voyage. Exactly. And actually, in 2017, when Enda Kenny went to Patrick's Day to the White House and Trump was in the White House and Kenny very pointedly said that St. Patrick is the patron saint of immigrants. Yeah. Nudge, nudge, nudging Trump in the rib.
以来都存在着轻微的紧张关系。但这可能会鼓励——一直以来都存在着轻微的紧张关系。我认为直到大约 20 世纪 60 年代初，它们才最终被法律允许开门营业。没错。纯粹的基督教、天主教对圣帕特里克节的遵守，与从长远来看显然已经演变成的那种享乐主义、你可以称之为爱尔兰裔美国人式的圣帕特里克节之间，一直存在着那种紧张关系，也就是到处喝酒狂欢、在街上聚会、戴着绿色帽子、喝着爱尔兰啤酒、橙色啤酒。所以许多爱尔兰人其实觉得这相当具有冒犯性。这很奇怪，不是吗？爱尔兰与爱尔兰裔美国人之间存在着那种鸿沟。我记得有一次我住在明尼苏达州时去过——他们在明尼苏达州圣保罗市开了一家爱尔兰商店，里面全都是橙色的胡须和爱尔兰小妖精（leprechaun）的图片之类的东西，但同时也有非常天主教的十字架那种意象以及两者的结合。我甚至在当时就想过，来自你知道的——19世纪90年代都柏林的游客会对这个作何感想？
So I think that that's kind of very helpful. I think, yes. So Patrick is claimed by both catholics and protestants so amar you know the great cult center of patrick is it got taken over by the church of ireland yeah i think that in uh you know in the late 90th early 20th century he obviously became associated with irish nationalism and therefore with the kind of the catholic strain of that so that's also um very much a kind of part of it so it becomes a um a national holiday in ireland in 1903 yeah you know the prompting of an irish nationalist mp yes i remember westminster and uh but also they they specify that the pubs should be shut on that day well there's always
他们自己国家身份中这种媚俗的一面。嗯，我确信，圣帕特里克节演变成一种狂欢，与天主教作为爱尔兰境内声望和道德之源的崩溃同时发生，这绝非巧合。我认为，关于德鲁伊、关于蛇的很多事情——如果你比较新潮，如果你喜欢——你知道的，小妖精（让我们用“小妖精”作为爱尔兰是一个充满灵魂出没的神秘土地这一观念的代名词），
been a slight tension but it might encourage that there's always been a slight tension there. But it might encourage that. I think it's only kind of early 1960s that they're finally legally allowed to open. That's right. There's always been that tension between the purely Christian kind of Catholic observance of St. Patrick's Day, but also what is obviously worn out in the long run, which is the sort of hedonistic sort of what you might, I suppose, call the Irish-American kind of St very what you might, I suppose, call the Irish American kind of St.
那么事实上，帕特里克是一个隐隐透着阴险的人物，因为他把他们驱逐了。好吧。我认为这里存在着一种有趣的紧张关系。好了，汤姆，出于显而易见的原因，我觉得我们应该以这场狂欢来收尾。让我们走向狂欢吧。因为我很想知道你喝 Beer 52 的免费啤酒喝得怎么样了。嗯，现在大约是 11 点钟。是的。我的意思是，说实话，这通常是我开始喝酒的时间。我已经喝完那一箱了。我当时正在把它扫光。你喝了多少？
Patrick's Day, which is all about kind of drinking and partying in the streets and wearing green hats and sort of Irish beer, orange beer, orange beers. So a lot of Irish people actually find quite offensive. It's a weird thing, isn't it? That's sort of the chasm between Ireland and Irish America. I remember once when I lived in Minnesota going to they had an Irish shop in um St Paul Minnesota and it was all orange beards and pictures of leprechauns and stuff but also the kind of the kind of you know the kind of very catholic kind of the crosses and that kind of imagery and the sort of combination of the two things but I sort of wondered even at the time what would a visitor from you know know, 1990s Dublin make of this?
八罐，全喝完了。不过你可以——看那个说明，如果你想的话，其实可以订 10 罐。事实上，我打算再订一箱。我太喜欢了。你可以通过优惠活动来做到这一点，对吧？是的，你可以。但你可以领取你的免费箱装啤酒。我的意思是，这是一件非常了不起的事。我已经拿到了我的免费箱装箱，所以，我太喜欢了。你可以通过优惠活动来做到这一点，对吧？是的，你可以。好吧，你可以领取你的免费箱装啤酒。我的意思是，这是一件非常了不起的事。
This sort of kitsch side of their own national identity. Well, I'm sure it's not a coincidence that the kind of the transformation of St. Patrick's Day into a kind of bacchanal has coincided with the collapse of the Catholic Church as the, you know, the source of kind of prestige and morality within ireland um and i think that also quite a lot of the um the stuff about the druids the stuff about the snakes if you're kind of new agey if you're into you know leprechauns let's use leprechauns as kind of shorthand for the the idea of ire of Ireland as a mystical land haunted by spirits,
我已经拿到了我的免费箱，所以我可能会再买一箱。但听众将能够在 beer52.com/ireland 领取免费的一箱。网址是 beer 这个词加上数字 52 点 com 斜杠 Ireland。汤姆，最棒的是，他们只需支付邮费，也就是 5.95 英镑。Beer 52 是世界上最大的啤酒俱乐部。他们每个月都会给你寄来一箱啤酒，而且这比你在超市里能找到的那些平淡无奇、毫无生气的工业啤酒要好得多、好得多，我绝对可以用人格担保这一点。
then actually Patrick is a faintly sinister figure because he banishes them. Okay. I think there's a kind of interesting tension there. Well, Tom, I think we should just end with the bacchanal for obvious reasons. Let's go to the bacchanal. Because I'm curious to know how you've got on
根本没有可比性。对吧，多米尼克？根本没有可比性。如果不喜欢黑啤酒，你可以选择仅含淡色啤酒的箱子。此外，其中还包含一本以爱尔兰为主题的发酵杂志和一些小吃。那些小吃也很棒。我可能会把它们当午餐吃。如果你不喜欢——而你绝对会喜欢的——你可以随时暂停或取消。所以网址是 beer52.com/ireland。听过我们的狄更斯和圣诞颂歌主题播客的人都会知道，我将为小汤姆（Tiny Tom）留上一杯。就此而言，我们祝大家圣帕特里克节快乐，再见。再见。感谢收听《历史剩下什么》。
with your free beers from Beer 52. Well, it is now kind of 11 o'clock. Yeah. I mean, that's normally the time where I start drinking anyway, to be honest with you. I've done the case now. I was polishing it off. How many have you had?
想要获取额外单集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请前往 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。
Eight, all eight. But you can, looking on the thing, you can actually order 10 if you want. I'm going to order another case, actually. I enjoyed it so much. Which you can do with the special offer, right? Yeah, you can. But you can claim your free case. I mean, this is an extraordinary thing. I've had my free case, so, I enjoyed it so much. Which you can do with the special offer, right? Yeah, you can. Well, you can claim your free case. I mean, this is an extraordinary thing.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐剩下什么》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集和抢先购买现场门票的权益，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。
I've had my free case, so I'll probably buy another one. But listeners will be able to claim a free one at beer52.com slash Ireland. That is beer in the numbers 52.com slash Ireland. And Tom, the amazing thing is they'll only need to pay for the postage, which is £5.95. Beer 52 are the world's biggest beer club. They'll send you a case every month and it's much, much, and I can absolutely vouch for this,
我已经拿过免费的箱子了，所以我可能会再买一个。不过听众可以在 beer52.com 连线 Ireland 领取一个免费的。也就是 beer 加上数字 52 点 com 连线 Ireland。汤姆，神奇的是他们只需要支付 5.95 英镑的邮费。Beer 52 是世界最大的啤酒俱乐部。他们每个月会给你寄一箱，而且——我绝对可以为此担保——
much more enjoyable than the bland, masculine sluggish you might find in the supermarket. There's no comparison. Isn't that right, Dominic? There's no comparison at all. And if dark beer is not your thing, you can choose the light only case. And also included is an Ireland themed
比你在超市能买到的那些乏味、寡淡的工业啤酒要享受得多。根本没法比。对吧，多米尼克？完全没法比。如果你不喜欢黑啤酒，你可以选择纯淡啤酒箱。其中还包含一本爱尔兰主题的
ferment magazine and a couple of snacks. And the snacks are excellent too. I might have them for lunch. And if you're not enjoying it, which you absolutely will enjoy it, you can simply pause or cancel anytime. So that is beer52.com slash Ireland. And people who listen to our Dickensian
《Ferment》杂志和几包零食。零食也非常棒。我可能会把它们当午饭。如果你不喜欢——虽然你绝对会喜欢的——你随时可以暂停或取消。网址是 beer52.com 连线 Ireland。听过我们狄更斯和
and Christmas Carol-themed podcast will know that I shall be saving a glass for tiny Tom. And on that note, we wish you a very happy St. Patrick's Day and goodbye. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History.
《圣诞颂歌》主题播客的人都知道，我会给小汤姆留一杯。说到这里，我们祝大家圣帕特里克节快乐，再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。
For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, Rest is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde.
想要获取独家节目、抢先收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区“历史的余烬”，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点八卦的地方，在问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目和优先购买现场门票的权利，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。